what's happening [ __ ] the church
is brought to you by on it
for all your supplement needs go to
honey.com right now and press in church
bam and get 10 off
and the stuff gets delivered right to
your [ __ ] doorstep
number two
beloitin is the number one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
in the country
blue apron's mission is to make
incredible home cooking accessible to
everybody all right
cooking together brings us a strong
family bond
research shows that blue apron families
cook nearly three times more often
than most bummy families anyway
right now go to blueapron.com and press
in
joey and good
you get your first three meals for free
and with uh free shipping it's great you
get your first week for free there you
have it
blue apron
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here crystal leah here yeah
here
[ __ ] great to have you on the show
i'm happy to be here i'm happy i was
asked
that song takes me back to actually like
hearing that takes me back to high
school that which would be the second
time that song came out again right
right the second time that's like a
reissue that was a uh
that's [ __ ] crazy how music can do
that dude i used to listen to that every
day
did you like that album the movie when
it first came out you were in all in
yeah
no not you i fainted what do you mean i
can't see [ __ ] really blood so that
heroin scene i went down the girl on a
date put a razor net in my mouth to wake
me up and i came back here so i never
really finished a good race in that
commercial yeah then i went back when i
lived in seattle and watched the whole
thing and now whatever is on that watch
you know what honestly pulp fiction is
one of those movies i think that if
if you watch it now
it's not as good because so many [ __ ]
filmmakers and movies have copied that
that now it's like so annoying and old
so it [ __ ] it up for watching that
movie which was the original version of
it you know what i'm saying like you'll
watch all these goofy movies like this
and then you'll watch this movie it'll
be like ah [ __ ] it's another one of
those movies you know what i mean like
kids would see that [ __ ] but but it was
the first of its kind right
no it was i thought it was great i
didn't know who the [ __ ] he was yeah
and i thought it was great and i think i
went back and watched true romance or
something
oh yeah yeah i came out yeah he had a
few movies and i you know
they're great movies even now you watch
your romance it's [ __ ] yeah nah
they're [ __ ] awesome yeah it's
[ __ ] crazy
you a movie buff i mean
no i would say no my brother has sees
literally everything but um no i'm not
i'm my brother i got one brother sister
he's younger no sisters no and what do
you mean he watches that he just watches
everything i mean first of all he's a
he's a filmmaker a writer writer
director but um so he just he thinks you
know it's his business but he also loves
it yeah but he'll see i'll just be like
yo if i want to know if something's good
i'll just ask him even though he [ __ ]
hates everything you know he's one of
those guys
but uh yeah
that is a weird thing with people in
like the film and tv industry even when
i went to school like everyone like they
you get there and like i was so excited
to start film school like what's your
favorite like every time you have a move
talk about movies unless it's like
breathless or something black and white
they're like oh this that's terrible
it's garbage yeah what the [ __ ] is
breathless it's a french movie yeah from
like that i remember that i had the
[ __ ] vhs
because i used to like love
like all that like i was a
huge stealing john cassavetes fan like i
would watch all his movies and i'd watch
him over and over again when i was like
23. and that movie my dad gave me that
vhs and he was like you got to watch
this one and i never watched it just
because it was so it's like so black and
white and so [ __ ] one of those movies
yeah it's not it's it's not an easy
movie to watch like the 20s i would
think it's one of the first ones
it's fine when you're learning the
history of film but like there's i don't
know it was like made with like a
lumiere or whatever the [ __ ] those
cameras are right
what hit me with some cassavetes movies
uh women under the influence was a big
one my favorite one was husbands which
not many people saw but i haven't seen
that it was my favorite one
when i was i my dad had a vhs copy of it
and i watched it and um
i loved it and you couldn't even find it
back then i don't you'll probably find
it somewhere now but it was so like it
came out in like
either
i think in the either
like either 79 or like early 70s or
something like that or maybe 80 but it
was so good it was about three dudes one
was peter [ __ ] ben gazera and the other
one was john cassavetes and their friend
dies and they basically
decide that they're like uh they're like
this funeral was [ __ ] they didn't
even say anything personal about them so
they go out and they kind of like have a
night or two of debauchery um and they
just don't go home to their wives and
then they end up in paris just kind of
like being like these [ __ ]
you know dudes that are trying to deal
with their friend's death and it was so
good because it was so funny without
being it was just like being a guy it
was like it was like it's exactly what
it's like being a guy i thought that
movie husbands is is the it's to me the
best movie uh
that i've ever seen because because of
that because it doesn't try and they're
so funny but but they're obviously
friends and cassavetes had a really good
way of doing that but uh i even like
killing of the chinese bookie which
everybody [ __ ] hated but i love that
movie i love bengali
is this [ __ ] when there's a scene in the
in the killing of the chinese bookie
where he's in a limo
and the whole scene is him sitting in
the limo and then at the end of the
scene he just says
he says i'm terrific and that [ __ ] like
i'm i'm howling when i watch [ __ ] like
that um
and cassavetes was so good at at um
at that like machismo male kind of uh
[ __ ] that was his [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
that was the [ __ ] that's what he loved
capturing yeah he liked that tough game
yeah i loved that [ __ ] so he he was he
was always my favorite did you ever see
ben gazzara
in that [ __ ] movie with uh spike lee
with the 44 caliber killer where they
have to go to him he's the mob boss he
was playing john gotti
no like an off-colored john gotti
in in 44 in that stupid [ __ ] movie
that spike lead which i enjoyed the
movie i'm just saying that i don't know
what is it
44 caliber killers that's what it's
called whatever that dude that killed
people in new york
oh uh with with [ __ ] oh yeah what
john leguizamo
uh sam uh somewhere
was that somewhere
i saw that yeah
yeah i don't remember that benghazara is
who they go to or my boss that they go
to okay to uh
try to get this help
oh okay and he's like look i enjoyed
that movie he's like look at this
for years you go to the police oh yeah
now you come to me and sit down boys
have a little spaghetti and he [ __ ]
invites them down and you're like jesus
christ i love that [ __ ] that italian
[ __ ]
you know what's another scene that i
always thought was a brilliant scene
that had
no comedy involved
but just the whole scene is hilarious
good fellas when they go to the mother's
house oh yeah forget it you're sitting
there with your mom but there's a guy in
the [ __ ] trunk just that alone yeah
that alone that alone was and and i
could see like we gotta get in the trunk
we gotta hurry yeah [ __ ] no they're
pouring ketchup and salt and pepper and
asking her for seconds and [ __ ] yeah
then they asking for a knife ma we gotta
borrow a knife yeah yeah yeah you know
that whole scene yeah yeah after like
the first time you watched it did you
chop up that body yeah you didn't know
how you felt yeah but now it's that much
[ __ ] love yeah if it comes on you
watch that scene and go that is [ __ ]
hilarious my favorite movies my favorite
movies and this is what uh cassavetes
did this uh really well my favorite
movies you you
this i don't know maybe it sounds dumb
but you don't have to watch it from the
beginning to the end you can like turn
it on and it's on and you can watch like
35 minutes of it and you and and like
goodfellas is like that to me you know
and and and i like those movies
because it's less about the what happens
and more about the characters you know
it's so funny when you get home and
goodfellas is yeah even if it's on a
paid channel yeah i always watch to see
what time it started so if it's 10 after
10
and it started at nine yeah that means
the billy bat scene is right around the
corner because it comes in an hour an
hour 15 hour 10 commercials they cut him
in yeah yeah a couple [ __ ] yous yeah
yeah so
i always if i look to see what time it
starts with billy batson come on you
[ __ ] watch billy batson that's a
shame he died last week oh yeah yeah guy
like
yeah he made his career like i know like
people say well you don't want it what's
the expression people always saying that
like you don't want to get uh what's
that typecast vision held yeah well he
never played a priest right like he
never played nothing else but a [ __ ]
gangster that's what you hired him for i
think and do the right thing
he played the guy in the car that's the
movie i've never seen do the right thing
yeah it took me [ __ ] there was two
movies
that it took you years to sell me
do the right thing was the first one
that took years to sell me let the
weapon i refuse to [ __ ] lovely now i
[ __ ] love it why why didn't you want
to see it i i don't know the trailer
maybe i just didn't i just wasn't in a
[ __ ] mood that's so i was into drugs
and getting my dick sucked and taking 12
credits i had no time to watch [ __ ] a
black top and a white copper
and then i had a warrant out for my
arrest and i couldn't leave the house so
i had to watch movies
so i said okay this is a good time to
watch movies when you got a warrant so i
went and i got [ __ ] lethal weapon and
above the law
stephen oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i [ __ ] you know i've always loved
mel gibson i don't give a [ __ ] with
anybody says you know people have bad
nights they say [ __ ] when they drink
they do they just say [ __ ] when they
have three drinks and that's why you and
i don't drink because we don't want to
say that i'm not getting a [ __ ]
problem with a microphone in your hand
so but i love
you know i loved all that [ __ ] i [ __ ]
enjoy uh i like the godfather yeah
there's a lot of bad mob movies but
there's a lot of good well that's what
happened well exactly what i'm talking
about they [ __ ] it up there were a few
good ones and now everybody thinks
they're going to make the next [ __ ]
godfather and then it's just like put a
bad taste in your mouth well the problem
was too the sopranos was just that good
yeah it was so good the sopranos took it
to such a level that he they they
explored every avenue yeah so even if
you were to write something now
what are you gonna [ __ ] write look at
these humps they're getting together
another movie yeah that that genre is so
yeah it's done it's done they can't sell
it yeah and every time i get an audition
and it says gino right
gino rocco right just turn it down
mm-hmm if you're still talking because
you know it's going to be bad yeah or
done yeah yeah yeah it's done it's done
so that's that's the [ __ ] thing but
i'm a movie guy too
and i like the guy movies i like
castlevania is that the killing of a
chinese i loved that movie jesus i
haven't seen that like 10 years and it
was just done about two or three months
ago it was on late night oh really yo
somebody had a long wow
yeah i have all those dvds man what made
jesus stand though um
i just always assumed i would do it
since you were yeah yeah yeah i always
like
my dad tells a story where when i came
in the room he was watching a jerry
lewis movie and uh and i walked in the
room and i was playing my toys and then
i looked up and i saw him being goofy
and uh just being silly and i and i
stopped and i looked at him and my dad
like you know registered that i was
watching him and i said and then i
turned to my dad and i said hey dad um
uh
is that uh
that man on tv is is this
is that his job
and he said what do you mean i said like
is his job to just make people laugh and
my dad said yeah and i said huh i said
and he makes money and he makes money
doing that and my dad said yes as a
matter of fact he makes a lot of money
and then my dad said i went like this
and he was like that was the moment
where he knew that i registered like oh
[ __ ] like you can do that i wanted to do
that because i was already like a cut up
you know what i mean even though i was a
little kid
but yeah i never imagined i wouldn't be
a stand-up there's a scene of a nutty
professor
yeah was the last time you watched i
mean
not i mean so long ago next time you get
a minute there's one scene and another
professor when he goes to psychological
psych
psychologist's office
and he goes in i don't remember oh my
god lee he's going with a suit like he's
a [ __ ] nutty right the only thing i
remember is the working out yeah he's
like
but now he's like smooth
good look and he's got like a [ __ ]
tuxedo he's smoking his cigarette his
nails are done and he goes in to see
this guy and he goes doc i got i got a
problem or something i think i got two
personalities
and the guy
the guy gives him
something the guy says something to him
or he goes doc
the last time somebody told me that they
gave me a bill for 42. dollars he goes
the guy goes what did you do he goes i
gave it to the other guy and told him to
split the bill 21 something stupid yeah
yeah yeah but i [ __ ] died that's the
only part i like
many professors i i don't even know if i
like that movie or not it's probably so
dated though now right
my you know what i wish they would
[ __ ] do and that they don't do
anymore are the or are like the naked
gun or the airplane movies those movies
to me
nothing funnier and they don't do them
anymore they don't know how they're
going i know they were they trying to
for a while well they tried they do like
the version of it now is like what is
like the
it's like the scary movies right [ __ ]
which is just different it's it's not
even the same and i
but like the airplane movies and the and
the naked gun and
that [ __ ]
i don't know people i feel like people
think that's corny now but [ __ ] that i
love it even cannonball run
oh yeah yeah
the second one was corny but the first
one was good not they forgotten how to
do that we were watching lenny bruce
yeah before the show yeah
to stand up you got a camera i put it on
yeah you watch a [ __ ] stand up yeah
what have they done to stand up now cut
it all out 22 [ __ ] cameras we put a
camera on top yeah to show the bald spot
on you who gives a [ __ ]
just show me direct cut me up at the
waist you don't got to show them going
like this they can hear it yeah yeah
we've just
not to mention the [ __ ] cranes are so
distracted when you're on stage
they're so distracting you don't like
wreck you probably don't think about
this at home but like when you're on
stage and there was there was an eye
line on my last special where i was
looking at it like where i always looked
this way and i didn't realize that i
mean i've been doing the act for a year
and a half and i didn't realize that
that was where the crane is going to be
and it's just so [ __ ] distracting it
[ __ ] you up sometimes and for the
audience too cause then like yeah
there's a crane in there it's so bright
yeah two when you do a special would you
do yours your last one chicago where at
the zany's oh yeah and the other one
rosemary oh yeah yeah rosemary yeah i
like zany's rosemary a lot blue collar
chicago's awesome yes the one downtown i
bomb
really i go down there just to eat a bag
of dicks and things down there they just
stare at me the one in the [ __ ]
suburbs they bring knives to stab
themselves to stop laughing
you know the one down there is like a
[ __ ] i can't imagine you bombing that's
not hilarious it's a [ __ ] nightmare
it's there's some clubs that yeah it's
weird right like maybe it's the room or
some [ __ ] there's some clubs that i
think at first i used to go you know
what it's me putting [ __ ] in my own head
it's me going i don't like that room
there's some rooms you just [ __ ] died
that that the war something is not i
still don't know i still i've done stand
up now it'll be 11 years coming up i
still don't know sometimes i i don't
know if it's
because who's that the seinfeld that's
like it's never the room it's never the
audience it's always you i just don't
know if i believe that
i don't know if i don't know if i don't
know if i believe that maybe it is true
but like maybe maybe sometimes you bomb
and you're like
i think it's the audience how is it how
is it me at this point i've done this
for so long
do you know what i'm saying
i don't what do you feel i don't know if
uh just for example with comedy movies
not even stand up if you go to on like
an opening night like i saw borat
opening weekend with a pack theater and
i was dying it's gonna be bonkers people
were falling out of their seats right
you watch borat at home whatever it's
not gonna be like that and it's not as
funny it's just so i don't know if maybe
like some rooms
i don't know maybe the the people in one
area were bad so then everyone around
them in a 10 table radius gets weirded
out or maybe there was a lot of traffic
coming and it's it's a weird
there's a lot of external things that
because i've seen joey do his act
yeah hundreds of times and it changes
but i've seen it in succession and
there's different nights that go better
than like we had a
i mean you did you changed the set a
little bit but you you did the first
show on the second show and the second
show for the
special for the special was a lot better
than the first show yeah the first show
was just a [ __ ] nightmare so it's a
really first show you put a lot of dude
i i had the first show on my last
special was a nightmare dude and i was
like what i i literally afterwards was
like my is over i thought so
it's so dumb to think that but like you
do in that moment i had the mic was
cutting out and [ __ ]
and i would i was like it was it was one
of the first times where i was like
yelling at people
like in my career i was like what the
[ __ ]
who can i yell at for this like i'm
yelling and [ __ ]
yeah and uh and then the second one went
when went well and then
and then when i rewatched them the first
one because the mic was cutting out i
had this energy where i was like no
[ __ ] not today and we used a
lot of that [ __ ]
because it was way better way better
so you never know but yeah and it's it
was interesting we had uh one of our
friends watched this the set and i think
they said something to the effect of it
might have even been the last one where
where the crowd isn't that as into it
you
like the way you told the jokes was a
lot more like the way that you had
prepared it and then sometimes when the
audience is going crazy maybe you ad-lib
a little bit more so it's better in the
room but then totally dude that's that's
a hundred percent true
dude when you you see some of these guys
that [ __ ] murder at the comedy store
and then they have a special and they're
like okay this is my special here we go
that's a bad that's a bad vibe man i
have it
really because here's the thing here's
the thing that you gotta i think like
comedians have to realize is when you're
doing when you're doing your special
you're in the room and you're it it's
the energy of the room that's feeding to
this moment but you have to remember
that people are gonna be watching this
[ __ ] here
they're gonna be [ __ ] there's
close-ups of your face so if you're
amped up doing the [ __ ] it's not gonna
read at home
you're gonna look like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i i i remember thinking that because
of
something i did
because i've been acting you know what i
mean i've been acting since i was 16.
and i remember whenever i would do some
[ __ ] and then see it i would see it
later on tv i'd be like oh that's what
that looks like i moved my face too much
do you know what i mean and i'm very
animated as it is on stage so
you know you are too so you got to think
about that [ __ ] like about your face and
like i've seen people [ __ ] up their
specials because of that well for my
case it was completely different in my
case it was it was that wasn't there
thinking that was seinfeld
i'm not signing for a dog
i'm terry diaz yeah yeah why are you
[ __ ] doing sci-fi who the [ __ ] are
you
to go up there and do your jokes yeah
precisely right right right right right
i went up to the second side and i go
that's it
if i went back there i smoked a joint i
even smoked a cigarette i don't know
i smoked the marlboro light just to
bring me back a little bit and i changed
it all up this was the second show for
your second show focusing on the awards
stop focusing on them yeah yeah yeah
yeah
[ __ ] work i know you know uh they
always said that mom and brandon didn't
know the words in the godfather he
didn't know his lines but he knew the
character yeah yeah if you know the
character the words would come out yeah
i was going up there trying to be
seinfeld trying to be [ __ ] uh
monologist to try to be uh what's the
guy that developed the signed uh
bell show oh uh neil brennan i was
trying to be like brandon you know i'm
not male brandon yeah and then the
second show is like hold on slow that
down
this is who i am yeah it was a complete
different ballgame
even though they did use some stuff yeah
yeah yeah from the first show well
because you don't know you don't know
how it comes across but yeah you're
getting your head and [ __ ] it's hard
when you're shooting a special it's
[ __ ] hard because they're like this
is it this is the [ __ ] this is fight
night this is what i've trained for you
know what i mean and it's hard to even
though when you get on stage you you
know you hope to fall into that rhythm
to where like okay i've been doing this
for years but it's it's still hard to to
not [ __ ] think okay this is what it
is this is the moment this is what the
world is going to see
potentially millions of people are going
to see this
people that don't know who you are are
going to see it and be like [ __ ] this
guy [ __ ] this guy you know what i mean
yeah so i had the weirdest thing
happened to me during my special what
ready to run ready for this yeah
first spatula i bought first taping
i go inside
i comb my hair i smoke some pot i get my
head together i come out [ __ ] first
20 minutes it's gold
i'm home free nice yeah oh that feels so
good guess what happened what
these two [ __ ] jerkoffs no
right in front of me started fighting
what a girl and a boy oh get the [ __ ]
out of here and you did it at zany so
it's intimate so he was like this that's
the thing
and he's hammond and she's embarrassed
as [ __ ] she's a sweetheart that brought
you a loser yeah yeah she was probably
coming by herself right right right and
then on the way out here i'll go see
that loser with you right right now he
came and was you know he was saying [ __ ]
dalia i positioned my foot i swear to my
mother's grave bro
there was one point like the 24 minute
mark that i i watched the special and i
could see it really
i even positioned my thing and i was
just going to kick him in the face and
end it my career was going to end yeah i
get it right there so you saw it on
stage oh on stage they're fighting oh no
i'm on stage because i'm watching them
and i finally gave them like a look and
i went back and i didn't want it to see
on my face yeah i was sweating bullets
that my career was gonna come to a
[ __ ] end yeah and i go you know what
i'm gonna position my hip and i'm gonna
kick him yeah right in the [ __ ] face
once and for all yeah but in the middle
of this story like oh jordan get it
together folks
how crazy is that and you're telling
jokes during all this i'm telling jokes
i was gonna go out there and just choke
in the deck and then the staff came over
to me and they said they didn't know
what to do yeah they didn't know right
he's right up front what would happen if
they approached him and now we have a
[ __ ] argument and now i'm on stage so
that's what happened i was about to kick
this [ __ ] guy
right in the [ __ ] face and then the
guy over here
said something to him yeah yeah oh no he
said hey bro that could have gone
together and i just said woof no that
was one of the worst nights in my
[ __ ] life that that that i wanted to
kick him in the [ __ ] head
i i i get like a lot of like
did this [ __ ] drives me nuts
i get it at shows but like when you're
shooting a special i get a lot of these
whoo
and you're like all right i don't need
this [ __ ] for you're stepping on my
punch lines with woos
do you know what i mean these chicks and
and they think they're liking you which
they are but it's like ah he's gonna
have a
what are you doing laugh or don't laugh
that's all i ever want don't laugh
you're gonna whoo what the [ __ ] you
you know how [ __ ] stupid you gotta be
to woo
you're [ __ ] stupid you gotta be the
whoop you're not [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] i honestly don't give a [ __ ] if
you're out a [ __ ] angels game you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] if you will
i [ __ ] hate it it drives i never
understood it
i never got it so i never i never got
the memo on you whistlers at your shows
like like the girl like the people can
do like i can't even do it yeah that
that like
or whatever the [ __ ] right the thing
about that is at least that's only going
to be in the beginning okay you know no
nobody's going to do that if you do that
[ __ ] in the middle of i'll [ __ ] walk
out and strangle you but if you i'll get
my openers to [ __ ] do that [ __ ] i get
my opener to come on stage i'll walk out
and strangle you but like yeah the woo
thing happens like every [ __ ] four
minutes somehow no
they just i've noticed that on
at some shows like they have like
instead of a laugh they have a go to
either saying or noise or they clap real
loud
it's really
it's odd did you see that have you seen
the the this was this is great have you
seen the eddie eddie murphy's on stage
and it's like i don't know what it's
from it might it's an outtake i don't
think it was on any special but where
he's oh [ __ ] and then charlie murphy's
some girl says something and charlie
murphy says shut up [ __ ]
and you hear it and it sounds like eddie
murphy because it's his brother what is
that from dude that [ __ ] killed me i
just saw it that's so funny yes but it
went viral like last month last month or
something god that [ __ ] is so funny
like right away just shut up [ __ ]
before what i was telling you it was two
movies i refused to watch yeah yeah do
the right thing no
harlem nights delirious oh oh what is it
it wasn't delirious it was yes yes yeah
they cut it out deliberately okay okay
oh [ __ ] that's killer um i would not see
him and then my i took a sociology class
and they made me watch do the right
thing and i fell in love with it yeah
yeah yeah i haven't seen it and then the
other one harlem nights i refuse i
haven't seen that one either it's just
gonna be a bunch of black guys [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] i'm gonna relate and oh my
god yeah it's a [ __ ] masterpiece
richard pryor is great yeah murphy's
great yeah the chick is great i mean
it's a [ __ ] great movie red fox was
[ __ ] killing it yeah but no i
wouldn't watch those [ __ ] movies at
all i'm not watching that [ __ ]
do the right thing
it comes on once a month and i watch it
if i get home danny aiello
john
tuturo yeah it had a great it's a good
cast yeah it's a great cast wait not to
be boring but where'd you grow up
north bergen new jersey okay
but i had a lot of action in new york
city like when i was growing up i was
right next to new york city yeah so i
was there half the day
right so to get drugs you got to go to
all those [ __ ] crazy spots and you
just can't get drugs you got to buy a
slice of pizza and park the car right
so i got to see all those places in
brooklyn and the bronx yeah
so when i watched do the right thing it
just taught me how
where i came from
it's
19 different nationalities talking about
one another but at the end of the day
they make it work
that should do the right things about
about a black guy going to a liquor
store that's owned by a korean yeah and
he tells them i want batteries and the
guy can't pronounce battery right so he
goofs on them and but at the end of the
day everybody gets along you know i was
in shock when you said you were from
montclair yeah
i know mom dad everybody yeah well my
mom is from uh newark and then my dad's
from my dad's from queens damn yeah and
honey in the montclair
so they met at ithaca they went to
ithaca
yeah and then um you know they wanted a
place that was good for us because you
know what i mean so um it wound up in
montclair it's a great place yeah i
don't know how it is that i don't either
i heard it i heard it's uh awesome i
heard that they got that theater now i
guess dice was just there they were
telling me uh when i was doing uh the
stress factory but um they got some
theater there that's that's great
apparently but it's a montclair upper
montclair they got [ __ ] great houses
man you know i don't know back then you
can get them for a price but now no no
yeah you're in no fun yeah probably not
i used to play flag football out there
i think i played like five games because
who the [ __ ] is gonna get up sunday at
eight in the morning yeah when you're
19. and those are the worst days you
play flag football you get up monday you
think that you got hit by a truck yeah
but there was a guy that was five foot
eight
and he was like a middle linebacker and
he sold cars he was very sweet
we used to call him black sam that was
his name black sam turned out he was sam
[ __ ] mills he ended up playing for
the new orleans no saints and he ended
up being the smallest really
a [ __ ] all-time five foot eight
that's hilarious
that's crazy crazy we were playing flag
football with him wow
that's funny do you have a flag football
where did you play flag football there
was something in montclair like a
stadium and there'd be four games at
once like a park
so there'd be four games at once just a
bunch of 19. you know it's a men's
league you put two flags the line you
could tackle but you can't use your
hands
when was this like what year this is 84.
wow dude that's
84 83 around there 82. but how [ __ ] it
and i know this is i mean this is so
like this sounds so
what i don't know how it sounds but like
i was the fact that you were there in 84
playing flag football and i was four in
the same [ __ ] town and now we're
sitting here doing this [ __ ] podcast
that i think about that kind of [ __ ]
that trips me out like that's so wild
how people [ __ ]
connect and they were right next to each
other and now they're you know buddies
and [ __ ] brogan hangs out with eddie
brock eddie bravo's got a black belt
black kid nicest kid in the good world
he makes us live in
people he's brazilian
and he makes fun of him and he talks
brazilian brother's black no his friend
oh the kid got you okay yeah i was like
what the [ __ ] we're talking one day when
i came from cuba i got beat up at
central park yeah my mom put me in
karate
his father was my karate teacher no
that's funny that's 50 [ __ ] years ago
i'm 54. that's insane that's 50 how did
you even figure that out we just started
talking wow how did you get into jiu
jitsu yeah my father was a karate
teacher really where new york city where
90th street on upper west flight on
amsterdam are you [ __ ] mr orange yeah
oh no how do you know my dad i walked in
there when i was five with a black eye
wow he [ __ ] took me and made me run
and punched the bag and that's crazy so
those type of connections are the
weirdest so weird
when now they have don't they have that
thing now on uh
which i kind of like i mean i'm not on
match.com but i saw the commercial for
it yeah where you walk by them you can
walk by people oh yeah i heard about
what is it uh i don't know it's kind of
weird but it's like if you if you are in
a certain area with somebody
and maybe i haven't i didn't use match
but i mean it's probably like if you're
in an area with someone and then you
also both like certain things like
similar things maybe they'll tell you
it's called
they're they're they're ripping off
craigslist it's called yeah these
connections right yeah missed
connections on craigslist i never i
don't i don't know if anyone ever
ever found anybody but there's a section
on craigslist where it's like
yeah somebody people have definitely
been killed on it you were in starbucks
today wearing a yellow hat and i i wish
i said hi
yeah but that yeah and people have met
on that for sure though
yeah because that was like a big thing
like what was it like i don't know eight
years ago nine years ago where people
were making fun of yeah before this came
out really yeah
yeah
so what made you get to stand up at the
age of 25 yeah um why so late
well
okay i think it's this like i always
wanted to do it that was always the goal
but i just figured and this is really
stupid now that i am a stand-up i know
this but like i figured like it's so
hard like i was like why don't i get
credits first and then this way stand up
will be easier which is the
literally the worst [ __ ] person on
stage that did that and so um
so i just
worked to try and get jobs as an actor i
wasn't getting dick
so at a loss i was like all right [ __ ]
it i'm not getting younger might as well
start stand up now
and
and then i was like one show in i was
like
oh my god i wanted to do this i want to
do this forever so weird but and then
and i want to do it forever but also
i started when i was 25 like how old
were you when you started
29 yeah
so i i can't wait
so i can't imagine starting earlier than
25 because like
i mean these guys like chappelle and
like um bill hicks and they started when
they were 15 it's like i don't know what
the [ __ ] i would've even talked about
how crazy is that i used to go to
washington square park on sunday to get
valiums
and i would go to mcsally's air house
and i would stare
from mcsorley's i could see the circle
around charlie barnett and dave
chappelle as a kid
well i told dave that like really 20
years ago when i first met him about
dave i used to watch [ __ ]
charlie barnett to this day is one of my
[ __ ] comedy
the guy that he studied yeah i know i
know who he is yeah he was when he was
on miami vice i think he was [ __ ]
hilarious his stand-up was men's and
men's you know they still have
tapings of him at central at uh square
park
and it was pretty funny just the fact
that go to a park and do that [ __ ] and
run around and talk to different people
so chappelle used to do that chappelle
would be there opening up for charlie
wow
as a 14 or 15 year old or something
that's [ __ ] crazy now did i know he
was dave chappelle right not a [ __ ]
right he was a skinny black kid that's
the economy with the guy yeah you know
that's all i knew when i went home and
then over the years somebody said that's
the guy and then one day
at the miami improv like in 98 i go so
you were charlie barnett he was telling
me he was trying to develop
they were trying to develop something
with opie
uh whatever his [ __ ] name is uh about
charlie barnett but i guess it went
so what would they do
what would they do they would like stan
like they would be out at the click at
least charlie barnett washington square
park they'd stand on a table or some
[ __ ] they would stand in the middle of a
circle oh wow under a [ __ ] like
little bridgey thing and just do talk
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] in front of
a hundred tourists that's wild and ask
for dollar bills or whatever the [ __ ]
they did
really yeah i've never seen this
i heard about it though
yeah dude somebody's gotta do a
documentary about this thing yeah this
is just brilliant
[Applause]
we got a nice crowd here
i love a new york audience
i mean look at this crowd we're in the
village i love the village we get a nice
mixed crowd i mean look what we got we
got white folks
we got black folks
we got puerto ricans
puerto ricans
puerto ricans
we got a lot of [ __ ] puerto ricans
but i'm not going to [ __ ] with the
puerto ricans man cause y'all born with
knives
you're cutting me up and i won't even
know what you're saying me the media can
casino
and when you finish you go que pasa bro
cause i got into a fight with a puerto
rican kid and i was winning i was
bouncing around like sugar ray limited i
was bam bam bam it was only about that
tall
then all of a sudden he went like this
and i was surrounded
by a small puerto rican family of four
thousands
i like everything man let me buy it okay
dude this is [ __ ] amazing dude i like
pocketbooks
i love pogba books
i like the way white women walk with
their pocketbook when there's no negroes
around
i don't see no [ __ ]
and you know what else i like about new
york
i like the way different nationalities
go to work
everybody goes to work different for
instance caucasian businessman i need
some white people glasses
look at this people glasses is this
special or they just taped it yeah what
is this they're like cutting the
audience and [ __ ]
damn you can't see [ __ ]
[Applause]
i can touch my dick
how do white guys go to work they got
their briefcase
i can walk just like the white man going
to work watch this white guys
i love when they stand on the corn and
go
and how do black folks go to work we be
talking about
[ __ ] it i should get there by payday
wow this is amazing dude that's [ __ ]
interesting
he's gotta have 500 people there
but it's like it's what's crazy is like
he's gotta
project do you know what i mean if
you're puerto rican i like puerto ricans
y'all [ __ ] a lot
you have babies like jiffy popcorn
but like you couldn't do it this way in
a club no you know what i mean like that
i would talk about like knowing the room
that you're in you gotta like adapt to
it and it's just interesting to see
somebody have to do it outside like this
because of that
now [ __ ] with me
[Applause]
your japanese are korean
oh you all look alike
don't worry i'll be talking about [ __ ]
in a minute
in a minute you be going oh [ __ ] funny
now huh
can you imagine us doing this every
sunday and this is what you build
and people are telling like agents you
gotta go down there yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] insane this is it
and look at that 250 000 views
so
so chappelle used to open it for that
yeah that's crazy go to the top one
oh wow just
how long did he do that for
you guys next time you see him how the
[ __ ] do you start that
is like a spot
we got like a hong kong spot
you started you started out with
yeah and everybody yeah i mean i went
back to new york i saw you in about and
i was amazed
yeah it wasn't square park man i watched
this christmas
experience i do
i quit drinking smoking so i do have
work it gets me high you know
and
really they said you were here
and we're going this coming in right now
but you spirits you've been in about 20
minutes but we didn't care you want to
come either you need a chair
you were coming in and i had to get you
how long a flight is from hong kong man
you man i don't know
did you burn up before the fight
you burned one before the flight or now
how about the other guy asking his
stupid [ __ ] questions how long does
that [ __ ] google it
yeah
huh
yeah so he was like a young kid and he'd
go up there i don't know the exact story
yeah yeah yeah but i remember being up
there now like he's got it's not just
him he's got a couple guys with him and
then years later how did to start that
to create that and why she was at
washington square park yeah it's just
crazy like
i don't i know you know there's a couple
guys that could do that i could never do
that go outside and do comedy and i've
seen like i grew in in boston they have
faneuil hall where they have street
performers i've seen a bunch of street
performers and they all have like there
are like i think a lot of them are
amazing they do juggling they they have
a lot of acts but i've never seen anyone
do standing yeah no i haven't seen it no
yeah now the other guy goes down there
isn't there a guy on venice beach
for stanford stand up really really ears
collier
his name was on there also huh because
he was like a big time
venice beach guy for [ __ ] years he
would come to the store and he'd stand
outside and people would walk and say
hello to him he wasn't a tv person yeah
he had just been to venice beach for so
many [ __ ] years hmm
that's uh wow that's [ __ ] that blows
my mind you know i
left the store for seven years i woke up
and then i go this just isn't for me
anymore
i've been coming here six days a week in
the last seven [ __ ] years you know
mitchy's great to me
i stopped going to the store
there was some [ __ ] going on down there
i i just said before this blows up right
i'm getting the [ __ ] out right and i
just went out my way and what would you
do by the way where'd you go
like were you doing the improvs or what
the [ __ ] we got the improvs i had a
monthly show at brea
i had the haha
yeah different rooms at that time there
was all these comics had different rooms
all over
so i just did that i missed the store
and then i started when jamie called me
he goes come to the laugh
and that's the first time
i would talk to ari ari would always
tell me about you wait till you see me
and i like him oh cool and then i went
down to the [ __ ] laugh at you and
then i saw you and i went home my head
almost exploded
i'm like this [ __ ] kid is anime i
gotta get in shape
to hang out with these youngsters i
can't just go up there and hold the mic
no more that's because i hadn't been
over that hill no more i never really
did though yeah yeah yeah i was either
improv or comedy strong guy jamie never
liked me huh i only used to get spots
monday nights when gilbert booked the
room yeah so when he called me to go
back there
and i started watching him coming home
going [ __ ] that kid's good all right
thanks man he's jumping up and down out
there i gotta lose some weight but like
yeah people always go well before i go
to jiu jitsu i lose weight
before you go to the store you better
lose some weight dog because they got
some youngsters down there there's some
there's some animated guys now i mean
honestly i mean look at sebastian he's
the most animated
um
but i feel like uh but you're animated
in your own way
yeah you're not you're not jumping
around but you no but you're fun to
watch you know i mean like it's like
some comedians they could cut an album
and you don't need to watch them
you know and and it works i don't know
if my [ __ ] would work but it it adds to
it to watch you do you know what i'm
saying i always like that about stand up
me too you know what i mean i'm an
original room guy too yeah i don't think
my favorite room in the country the nuts
and bolts in that place like you
i could still bomb in there yeah
but it's really hard for me yes i know
all these cheap tricks in there yeah
yeah yeah to throw your voice in there
you can do a thousand things in that
room yeah yeah yeah but if i need to go
off that's the room
that's the room that if i go off and
have a heart attack and die yeah i don't
mind huh like as they're dragging me out
i won't be yelling i'm like at least
yeah my favorite spot yeah yeah it's not
like i was bombing and [ __ ] uh what's
the other improv in chicago there's a
more festive chamber
i've never played a position oh
really that's four days that you're
[ __ ] really why because it's in
middle nowhere or what it's in the
middle of nowhere so you have to like
everybody who performs like i'm born in
chicago yeah
at night you're like no you're not yeah
you're a [ __ ] schomburg where [ __ ]
death goes to die yes like that's where
death goes to die like that's how so
like if you die if you're going on if
like every time i went into that room
like i wasn't getting no love
like you're fighting for every [ __ ]
lap so you got to kick it up a little
bit so if you die in there right you're
like i hate you [ __ ] right but
if you die at the store you're like this
is great i know it is it's weird how
that is right yeah
it's weird how that is
what like you just said it was like
you're one of your favorite rooms in the
country and we're talking about how
different rooms affect you like what is
it about a room that that makes it
here's why i think the comedy store is
my favorite room at least one of them
uh because it i think it's the only room
that i know
that i've
i've played that's built for the
comedian and every other room is built
for the audience like you go to the
laugh factory
you walk in you're like oh you're
watching as an audience member you're
like oh here we go it's a show every
other place is like that but the comedy
store there's that light on you you
can't see the audience you might as well
be [ __ ] anywhere and and it's built
for the comedian in that way which makes
it much harder because the audience
isn't going to give it up if if you're
not [ __ ] real you know
um so that's why i love it and it also
it has a sense of like
there's like this like
i don't remember who said it but like
there's a sense of this and this sounds
pretentious but there's a sense of like
danger there like like somebody's gonna
throw something at you do you know what
i mean yeah there is
you know what i'm you know understand
like you walk into the comedy store as
an as an audience member you can walk in
in a good mood and walk into that room
and and you're literally like
where's my seat what's going on here it
changes your [ __ ] mood so it makes it
harder
and you got to be on the stage as a
comedian and break somebody
of that you know now it's a little
different because they got [ __ ] tv
everyone who goes on is like famous from
netflix and famous from [ __ ]
hulu whatever the [ __ ] you know it's a
little different they got you rogue and
sebastian you know david spade me
everybody's [ __ ] on tv so it's like
it's a little different now but but but
but um
back when
you well before when you were there and
then when you left like when i when i
went in i i got onto the comedy store
when you weren't there when what year
you used uh i probably started going
there 2008 nine
and you weren't there 208 2008 2009 and
um wow and uh it was it was like
i mean
nobody was on tv that was doing that
room and and and of course stand-up
became really hot you know after that um
but then it was getting really uh it was
getting hot
and then
and then we started getting like
good [ __ ] comedians not that the guys
weren't good but we started getting guys
that were recognizable but also like you
know like like you guys came back you
and rogan and and and and then and then
jaisal nick would come in and you know
and and and just guys that we weren't
getting because there was a weird vibe
there you know which is probably the
same reason why you [ __ ] laughed and
then it wasn't that vibe anymore and you
know ellie wong and just the people and
sebastian blew up and [ __ ] like that you
know and then and then and then it
became a then it felt like it became a
brand
where it's like you know
almost almost like where how def comedy
jam is it's like oh yeah i'll watch that
it'll be funny you don't know who the
[ __ ] guys are back then but you're
like yeah i watch it and then chris
tucker exploded and [ __ ] but it was def
comedy jam that was like now people i
think oh i'll go to the comedy store it
doesn't matter who's [ __ ] playing you
know but it wasn't like that when you
were gone it wasn't like that at all i
mean there were friday nights
where there were 30 people in the
audience
yeah yeah yeah i was there yeah it was
no different yeah these numbers now are
tremendous yeah
when i the reason why i don't go to
store a lot let me tell you why chris
now yeah when i say why why can't work
out yeah i know i know i know you gotta
go in you gotta go in between two
murderers and you gotta bring your a
[ __ ] yeah i know i know it kind of hurts
i have to i have to work hard on friday
saturday sunday because that's that's
the people paying attention i see you
right but you want the store i know it
was it was really there was a [ __ ]
charm to it monday nights was 90 people
thursday there was 10 because it was a
black fr uh tuesday mm-hmm so the white
comments didn't even call in they're
like why would i go down there to get
muscled right you know i'd always call
him because i knew mitchy liked
coast-to-coast guys mitzi don't like
well give me thursday early right right
friday
all she wants to see is sunday this
sunday yeah that's what she wanted to
see
so when you called in you had to take
the tuesday lump god damn it right eight
people had to leave the union
which is filled with chicks somebody was
giving out blow
i got to run over to the store to do a
15 minute spot for eight [ __ ] people
yeah but you needed the 15
yeah that was extra 15. so wednesday was
60.
thursday was 75.80
and then after midnight 18 strong till
two but that was i loved doing that i
loved doing it i loved doing that [ __ ] i
would take those [ __ ] 12 45 spots
when i was coming up they were the [ __ ]
they were the [ __ ] they were there was
nothing like that man and now now you
don't do those anymore you don't do
those anymore you certainly don't do
them in that room anymore but you know
you're not going to play i'm going to
put you no you would i would you would
but they're going to give you the 10 30
spot but you know let me tell you
something 13 people yeah one of them
awesome when they've listened
to every
[ __ ]
joke in the world they've already heard
the kardashians eight times yeah they've
already heard copernicus
didn't get up they already heard about
the rams they heard about the hurricane
elma they heard about everything you got
to go up there one o'clock and whatever
you were writing on that stupid piece of
paper all day i've been done seven
you gotta rip it out and just go up
there and that's when you get
lee you get so [ __ ] good it's
yeah i i honestly miss that and i think
about that all the [ __ ] time like
just calling adam and going i want one
a.m yeah but it's also it's also
different now because like people know
who you are and people know who i am so
if you're gonna do that it's still a
little different i mean you're never i i
always say like you're never you it is
true though you're never better than
[ __ ] trying to make 11 people laugh
you know like no matter how big you get
like they're still not gonna laugh if
it's not funny if there's 11 of them in
a room but still it's a little different
i i it was cool going
it was cool going knowing that those 11
people at 12 30 were thinking who the
[ __ ] is this guy
and now
you know even if three of them know me
from whatever you're not gonna get that
anymore do you know what i mean but
there's nothing like whipping 11 people
up into a [ __ ] frenzy
jesus christ i love you best sometimes
it was four people four people and you
they're dying and you're dying and at
that point you just take the chair sit
on stage you're like [ __ ] let me just
sit and talk to you guys
i saw
i saw so many when i first started at
the comedy store
i used to be kind of scared to go down
there some nights because i never really
knew what was gonna happen
like one night dave tyree threw a bottle
of joe oh jesus another night i was up
on stage some girl walked up and said
take your dick out
and i go before i take my dick out you
show me your [ __ ] on stage and she goes
okay
friday night
12 45 original room wow she pulled her
pants down to her ankles
people started clapping joey take your
dick out
i had to take my nutsack out bobby lee
and rogan on the side throwing money at
the stage because bobby was on mad tv
yeah yeah yeah yeah meanwhile i told the
chick you can't pull your pants down
right you gotta leave them down until i
put my dick out she's just so she's
standing up on stage with her [ __ ] out
pierced
with the piercing out like it was
nothing were you talking about your dick
or something no no nothing i just walked
up on facebook
she was hammered yeah she was with her
boyfriend and he
if you take out your dick
take out your dick i'm like take out
your [ __ ] [ __ ]
and she [ __ ] ripped up that [ __ ]
pants and took them down and the and
then when i turned around on stage you
know the patio they were all by the
glass yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
holy [ __ ] when i walked off that hats i
walked off for like 80 bucks and i was
happier than [ __ ] wow i did better than
if i would have done materials yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah they weren't [ __ ]
nuts i went on i went every [ __ ]
night in the original room there was
this dude vinnie favorita that would
bring a fart machine in
and put under people's chairs in the
original room
and then we would wait for brian
ultimate to go oh yeah and they would
start pressing the fart machine and he
would go [ __ ]
crazy on stage you never
knew
what to [ __ ] expect at the store yeah
and now
you don't get that no you don't yeah it
was even like that in 2008 a little bit
but i mean i'm sure it was even crazier
back before that how much of it has to
do with
like i love fenway i don't i don't i
don't want them to tear a family down
i'd still get to watch the red sox but
there's a feeling when you go into
fenway is there a feeling when you go
into this yeah 100 yeah i worry that wha
what what will happen to that place in
the next few years but i mean now i feel
like it's fine but like in 2010 we were
all like i wonder what the [ __ ] gonna
happen in this place because it was like
a ghost time there's a ghost time yeah
it's really weird to see what happened
2007
was even a [ __ ] worst ghost town yeah
it was
my mom was there when paulie had a
halloween party
and he served liquor in the parking lot
so the city closed the comedy store of
no booze for 60 days because he did that
oh jesus christ no booze till december
28th oh my god that's like the good time
too so from yeah from [ __ ]
on november 10th
to december 29th oh i must have been
brutal sodas
and you want to go up on stage for
[ __ ] a two soda minimum no food
no food back then so
i mean that
there was the audience must have been so
light
15. yeah oh [ __ ] for [ __ ] sake
tonight people were running out drinking
from a bottle in the hallway
no booze for two [ __ ] months
oh my god
nobody remembers that no i didn't even
know that that happened yeah yeah when
was that 2007
or before that oh this had to be
2001. yeah way before you had to be
waiting for that because i was that's
when i this door was [ __ ] dead yeah i
heard that from i heard that that it was
so dead in the early 2000s and i caught
i caught the tail end of the tupac days
wow
tupac got into a shootout at the store
no the bullet's still in there they they
drew eddie griffin out for that one they
banned it wait a minute hold on i never
heard this i'm a tupac's my favorite
yeah what happened tupac got into a
shootout at the store one night how have
i never heard eddie griffin invited him
to the [ __ ] store
while tupac is in there three bullets
went off from across the street and they
blamed ellie griffin certainly griffin
got banned for bringing tupac in there
are you [ __ ] me no true [ __ ]
story
holy [ __ ] tupac used to go in there with
eddie griffin oh man that's [ __ ] how
crazy is that that's amazing man
i saw mariah carey in there one night
with eddie griffin i saw raquel
oh so i [ __ ] i performed
for two people one time late at night in
the comedy store and one of them was dr
dre
it was dr dre and whoever he was with
and i was like i don't want to go up and
they were like and i think it was don
barros she's like no man i know why you
don't want to go up but you got to go up
you're a [ __ ] comedian and i was like
you're right i'll go up and i went up
and i just had a conversation with dr
dre
and it was actually cool because then i
talked about this on my podcast i think
but uh after uh i got off stage
he he was leaving and
there was
i like it was like maybe there were
maybe like two other people in the
audience it was like
there was nobody there and then they
left and everyone's like hey dre can i
get a pic can i get a pic dr dre and he
was like nah nah nah and he walked out
and he took a few steps past me out the
comedy store patio past the patio and
then i was like [ __ ] it i'm gonna ask
maybe like he'll appreciate that i was
on stage or whatever and i was like hey
dre and he literally like a movie
stopped and turned around and looked at
me and i said is it cool if i get a pic
and he [ __ ] went all right man and he
walked back and took the pic with me it
was a cool moment because it was like it
was like in my head i don't know he
probably think this but in my head he
was like all right like i respect that
like you know i'm a performer and he was
up there went up for two people you know
what i mean like it was a cool moment
for me
that he said no to everybody but then
like came back for me who else have you
seen up to anybody else just uh lately i
saw quentin tarantino um
mark ruffalo was there recently with uh
somebody else i think he was there with
chris rock but um
yeah no it's just been uh dr dre was
that was the wildest to me
uh there was one night there now that is
popping you know there was one night
there that james franco and like
leonardo dicaprio was going to be there
and elon musk they were all there
together or some [ __ ] so [ __ ] weird
is it so weird now that you can go to
the comedy store and literally end your
career with a bad set with all those
[ __ ] people in there now it's like
sometimes some nights it's a [ __ ]
star-studded event
when tom cruise came in really to pee
that's hilarious
years ago yeah indiana sunday night 13
people in the audience i'm on stage
and i see them walk into the
thing in the original room and then he
ran up the stairs and ran to the
bathroom
so when i came out of the thing i go and
you were on stage or no i was on stage
and i saw what i thought was time really
that's funny
and i [ __ ] got off
and then i forgot about it and i went
into the bathroom like 10 minutes later
and he popped out of this [ __ ]
wow like i forgot about it and he said
something to me
like he recognized i was on stage yeah
yeah yeah i said something back to him
that was it oh wow and him
cool i saw bon jovi in that one because
his brother used to be the manager
who when i first started at the company
matt bon jovi was the manager there
really yeah he's running a strip club
now in atlanta oh my god i didn't know
so matt bon jovi was the manager at the
store
so [ __ ] john matt bon jovi that's
hilarious how [ __ ] crazy is that and
he came in one night with that chick
the one that brad pitt dumped for
[ __ ] oh
aniston before her oh uh uh paltrow
paltrow okay he came in with gweneth
paltrow they were doing the movies oh
wow whatever the [ __ ]
they came in who else i see in that i
saw some crazy [ __ ] people chris
cornell uh-huh
1998 sitting in the corner with a hat on
not saying a [ __ ] word
who is the guy from the chili peppers
used to yeah always go always the singer
always always
yeah it's [ __ ] weird the people you
see up there oh oh oh one time i got off
stage and this dude with a cast on is
like
bro you're [ __ ] hilarious are you
[ __ ] i'm like this [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm like thanks man and i'm looking at
shyla buff
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm like what's up bro
thanks
my attitude changed such a [ __ ] fake
hollywood moment but i'm like get this
[ __ ] guy here oh you're in
transformers what's up
i'm surprised to hear you guys because
you've been here in l.a for a while i
don't think you get star struck anymore
but is it is it like exciting to perform
for these people sometimes sometimes i
mean like i said when you go on stage it
usually morphs into just another show
because you're that's what you do but
like yeah sometimes like
i remember when dr well dr ray was just
like four people in the room but like uh
quentin tarantino when he was there i
was like i want to do well because he's
in there you know what i mean or like if
or even if like if it's a comedian that
like like if chris rock is in the room
you're like i don't want him to think i
suck
do you know what i mean right yeah i can
understand the community indefinitely
but i don't know
oh you know what i had a meeting once uh
this was this is so weird what [ __ ]
happens in hollywood like
i had my agent called me this was years
ago and they were like hey you uh
so
francis ford coppola is doing a new
project uh they don't know what it is
yet it's it's like a really long script
they might do a mini series they might
do this and that
they're interested in italian americans
and they they the
um francis ford coppola's guy wants to
meet you and kind of like see what
you're all about so i went in and i met
with this guy fred somebody he like
produces a lot of his movies so i met
with this guy we were talking about
stuff we just had a conversation no
reading no nothing and he was like okay
cool bye then i get a call okay so
francis ford coppola wants to come see
you perform
and i'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me
okay this is the weirdest thing ever i'm
like all right okay let's okay like i
said no like now i'm not so yeah i'm
nervous now because france for college
directed great movie all the time right
so
he shows up
and ever the whole comedy store is like
francis for couples here to see you
like i'm like i guess so i don't know
what the [ __ ] happening right
so he comes and sees me do stand up
and i get off stage and he leaves he
gets off he came to see me weirdest
[ __ ] thing
so i'm like what should i do i remember
my brother was there and he was like you
should go say hi or something so i was
like okay i'll go up and i'll say hi so
i walked up and i was like hey i
appreciate you coming thanks a lot he
was like oh of course great job or
whatever he said you know
uh and then and then i did it and then
and then i got a call to do like a table
read with francis ford coppola and i
show up i'm like i don't know who's
going to be in here it was in a room as
big as this okay the table was almost as
big as the room
the chairs were like i mean
we had like this much room it was it was
uma thurman joe montana uh leave
schreiber um
[Music]
uh jason gordon-levitt what's that guy's
name uh gordon jason gordon you know
what i'm talking about
yeah um
uh and joseph joseph gordon-levitt and
then um uh philip seymour hoffman like
two months before he died
and and [ __ ] me
i don't know what's going on nothing
happened with it was it was a 400 page
script that we read it took eight hours
and i'm sitting there with all of these
stars
and i'm like this is amazing but by
hours five i was like what the [ __ ] is
happening like this is the it was so and
and everybody and and and i was playing
like all the ancillary parts like that
were like all the parts that were like
yeah i meet you over there there's some
[ __ ] or like pizza you know basically
these parts and uh
it was so wild man it was it was all day
there was a break in the in the middle
of it it was like a break where like we
were like we're eating pizza and
drinking a coke and
it was just it was crazy and then
friends for a couple of signed bottles
of wine and gave them to us i gave it to
my dad did you uh get the part no
because it never became anything it was
just like one of these things that like
all these
hollywood elite and [ __ ] me
it was a weird it almost feels like i
dreamt it like why the [ __ ] i i have i
still to this day have no idea why i ev
how i got involved have you ever walked
out of the room and said what the [ __ ]
just happened
like in like in a hollywood yeah um
i mean that was one of those but it was
what about going to the store uh-huh
getting hammered till two doing drugs
smoking pot you have a call back at 10
in the morning the next day on sunset
and western for a [ __ ]
stupid travalta movie
you get there
and it's travolta
and
who directed [ __ ] drugstore cowboy
uh
he's still
relevant he does something every couple
[ __ ] years
it is
vance oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah they're in the room at
10 05 in the morning and you didn't know
not a [ __ ] clue your age is probably
just like producers the other guy who's
reading is billy gardel
oh yeah so billy and me were fighting
for the [ __ ] same role
they didn't decide to give us both the
role
uh just to be two stand-up comics to
travolta's uh really singer what movie
was it this is called the
jimmy roselli story huh
three months of casting
contracts
signed after the holidays
and the call january third that said
travolta it's not happening not
happening is doing the scientology movie
oh battlefield earth battlefield earth
wow that's why we didn't do jimmy
roselli wow but it's [ __ ] another time i
had to be going to be cool same thing
yeah yeah you're in that right no oh i
lost it the guy died who they gave my
role to jesus that guy was great though
he was a great guy i forget
he was i did a transparent terry movie
and he was in that movie and we shared
like it was like a big trailer like just
i only had like one line i said just
sit with him he made me feel like i was
[ __ ] brad pitt that's cool i had one
[ __ ] line i threw a guy off the pier
yeah and he was in there
and he was on uh a show on cbs for a
long time great character actor i go
down to [ __ ] be cool i walk in
and there's
the little guy it's always sunny in
philadelphia
with [ __ ] travalta again devito
davido
i hate doing this [ __ ]
and you didn't know again no then i'll
[ __ ] call you to tell you i know i
know that's hilarious i was telling
ellen i remember reading for the
sopranos producers
and you know like i was just i would be
i was here 97 so it's 2001 and i'm in
the room and this is all you could hear
yeah from my handshake yeah from the
[ __ ] script those two times were
script shakers also wow i hate when they
call you with that [ __ ] and you get
there there's somebody completely
different yeah in the [ __ ] yeah you
hate people and
you're like what
when i got a call one day and they go
hey man
are you available to do table read
tomorrow sure okay we'll call you back
later they call back again are you
available tomorrow yeah
i'm gonna pick you up at one make me up
and they're like oh by the way we're
gonna do the table read and then you're
flying to [ __ ] santa fe to shoot the
movie right from the table reading are
you serious so i packed my bags again i
don't know dick yeah i had 35 hours to
go to santa fe and three cigarettes and
two joints wow they picked me up in
hollywood
a car picks me up i tip the guy the 20
so i'm down to like 15
i walk in the [ __ ] room and the first
person i see is that chick
the old lady who's real getting real
famous now for being she showed her tits
to greg garcia remember he was saying
that she's in raising hope oh the older
lady the older lady she's in there i'm
looking at michael irvin when i did the
longest yard they told me it was snoop
dogg
they go the movie's got snoop dogg in it
that's all we know so far adam sandlin
chris rock when i got there there was no
snoop dogg it was michael irv and nelly
i'm looking at [ __ ] burt reynolds
i'm looking at the guy from warriors in
48 hours what a trip i'm looking at all
these people oh my god cloris leichmann
gloriously
i'm a bus stop and ask me to leave yeah
that's how i feel like i got 15 in my
pocket i'm sitting next to michael irwin
and bert reynolds i'm sitting across
from romanowski
i got all these [ __ ] people around me
this guy over here this the the the
[ __ ] camera guy
he the australian guy was telling me
earlier mel gibson
jokes
wow he's the guy that did the
like he was the camera guy on the road
warrior yeah and the first two whatever
the other one yeah what was that mad max
in the road warrior so this guy came up
to me we were talking like oh you're
australian
talking
and i'm sitting in this room going when
is the [ __ ] roof
gonna fall on my head yeah
like that's how you feel in those
situations yeah especially when they
come to you until you did a good job
yeah yeah first time when the actors
come up they go bro that was a good job
you still feel like that's going to
happen you still feel like the roof's
coming down all the time when i'm in the
room like that i always
do you think like tom cruise still feels
like that i wonder does tom cruise walk
in now and he owns it
i hope there i hope so i hope there is
that
i hope there's that in it for him you
know what i mean like i have at some
point like i hope everybody gets some
sort of
butterflies well i think everyone does
but i would hope that you calm down or
i don't know maybe it's good maybe it's
good to get butterflies but it would be
it would be nice to be
i always get butterflies at the comedy
so you do
no matter who's up in front of me really
to the point i have to bring an anxiety
pill and put it in my [ __ ] pocket wow
when i walk those stairs yeah those
little three stairs yeah
it's lights out it's so joey weird
because you're so confident on stage you
know what i mean like that's so odd that
it's like that i mean i get that way
every now and then every now and then
like the butterflies are anxiety
i don't know
yeah a little i feel like i get both i'm
short breathed when i get up to yeah
when i first get to the original
doesn't matter who's on stage really no
matter what i wrote no matter what i
think as soon as i get the original room
and i sit in that little [ __ ] section
mitzi's chairs
my heart starts pounding
my breath goes out from under me i can't
catch my breath what not i actually went
the [ __ ] piano player
and i go dawg tell paulie my anxiety is
too bad i gotta get on stage and he told
paulie and paulie comes back he's like
what's the matter bro i go paulie she's
got the [ __ ] light
do me a favor and go up there for me let
me figure this out huh i couldn't even
breathe i had like a white balance
if someone's crushing i get that way
like like you last night when i followed
you i was like then i was like i got a
[ __ ] all right i don't want to be a
piece of [ __ ] no but you had such a good
time i said that was funny you were
laughing
it was fine
yeah i had a good i had a good set but
but you know if somebody's crushing
which you know
nine out of ten down there yeah
especially the lineups now
i know
sebastian it's like you just you gotta
so yeah so now i get it more often than
i used to but not if it's if they're not
crushing if they're having a find set
i'm like i'm i'm good no i'm i'm dying
back there even though whether you're if
you're bombing and getting booed i'm
still i'm more scared than you are like
i'm back there going my son
chris you know what i'm saying like i'm
worried about you plus i'm getting
anxiety
so now even last night at the start i
went up and ali won was doing great yeah
i caught the lot the first minute that i
was up there my heart was pounding yeah
that's fine my stomach was growling i
did that too last night but also
um
i don't i often don't watch the guy
before me because i don't i just i got
to be in the hallway i don't want to i
don't want to have to watch it and then
think things and then go up with a
[ __ ] mood i'd should just be you know
um
tommy told me the the old manager the
comedy store would tell me like you
should
have be in conversations with people
before you go on stage and i was like
dude i think he's right because like i
wasn't thinking i'd be just talking like
okay i'll go on stage now and just bring
that energy
um yeah
i like to get fired up i like people to
fire me up a little bit you want you
really want me to do well do something
that aggravates the [ __ ] out of me
like don't if if you like let's pray for
joey the bomb
don't aggravate me bring me like ice
cream and [ __ ] of a sandwich yeah but
like if you want like text me before i
go on stage i'll [ __ ] go up there and
blow that room apart like do something
to me i don't like
that i'll never forget when i get texts
is that what we say yeah i don't like
that [ __ ] that's why i disconnected the
thing like i'm done and it's funny one
night in san francisco i was bombing and
i saw rogan and red band had matching
phones
and i'm like these [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i went on stage i was so pissed at
them for having matching phones rogan's
like what the [ __ ] happened to you i got
you [ __ ] you got matching
[ __ ] phones i can't get pissed off
that's before like if i get pissed about
something before i go on stage that's it
that's it so i i like the talk thing
yeah i like when somebody brings it out
yeah yeah yeah like when somebody says
something to you that gets you pissed
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that that that fuels you to be
funny sure yeah especially if you're
that kind of you have that energy anyway
to where it's like almost feels like
you're arguing do you know what i mean
up there yeah so so that's that's good
for you for sure i could see that i
gotta tell you man you just shocked me
tonight because for a comic of 11 years
you have great maturity and composure up
there
ten years i wasn't doing what you were
doing not at all
not at all thanks man i didn't start
doing that to like 17 18 years
like you had me [ __ ] fooled i thought
you started when you were like 18 yeah
just head
up and see now yeah yeah 24 up
yeah put some greek restaurant hosting
some [ __ ] you have a great [ __ ] cop
man thank you where'd you get the name
man on fire is that your favorite movie
like me so yeah no i do love the movie
but the the
reason was because of um
i always had i've i've i've always had
this like notion
where ever since i was a kid about um
how
like
you could be so like sometimes you walk
into a room and you're like all right
this is my [ __ ] time to shine like
whatever the [ __ ] you're doing you walk
into a cafe feel that way you're like
i'm gonna walk into this cafe and it's
gonna be my i'm gonna be the guy in the
cafe i'm the [ __ ] guy who walks in
this cafe and the cameras are on me this
is all in my head but i walk in i order
a [ __ ] sandwich and everybody knows
i'm ordering a [ __ ] sandwich and this
is [ __ ] i'm gonna eat the sandwich
and this movie's about me that's just
what my sometimes and then you realize
nobody gives a [ __ ]
they're all ordering their own [ __ ] and
they're all [ __ ] day old and so
so i i came up with this thing where i
would be like you're not you're not
[ __ ] who the [ __ ] i'm not denzel
washington like i'm [ __ ] crystally
i'm just some guy
to somebody else i'm some guy and so um
so my whole the whole idea of like
you're not the man on fire you're just
the [ __ ] guy who's going to get a
bagel or whatever the [ __ ] uh was funny
to me and so i i thought what's the
funniest movie to to do that with and i
thought denzel it's gotta be a denzel
character because it made me laugh and i
was like oh man on fire it's great and
then one night on stage i just said it i
was like you're not the [ __ ] man on
fire and i was like i think that's it
i don't know it was an idea that i like
besides the fact that i i i would make
them i would try to make the material
funny it was the idea behind that that i
thought oh it kind of means something to
me so it made me it made me charged to
do the material you know you're a
[ __ ] trip
[Laughter]
what's a lot coming from
um uh i don't know i'm i'm doing uh like
we were talking about before this
podcast i've been enjoying uh doing my
own pocket i mean i'm on a episode 35 or
something but it's fun it's fun to do my
own podcast congratulations so i've been
doing that
i have another tv show in development
that i kind of shouldn't say too much
about because i don't know what's
happening with it yet but um so i'm
doing that and then just working on
stand up i got tour dates and [ __ ] is
that the youtube red shirt yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so uh i think youtube red's gonna be a
great [ __ ] channel yeah i do too man
i walked in the meeting skeptical about
like i don't know about because you know
i think youtube he's like i just like
i'll upload it myself you know what i
mean but then they were talking about
all the all the [ __ ] that
they're working with like the guys that
like have shows coming out on there like
doug lyman and [ __ ] and like
you're like all right all right i think
there i think honestly they're going to
be a force to be reckoned with i think
so too yeah i think so too yeah so i
think it just makes sense yeah
and you two how much a month now i mean
i like to do two weekends out of a month
um i got this movie in uh
may and i had to reschedule a bunch of
[ __ ] and every time i had to reschedule
i was in toronto for like five weeks so
i had to reschedule like two or three
dates and every time i do that i'm like
whatever the club wants just i feel bad
like tell and they all picked [ __ ]
september so this month i'm like killing
myself every weekend but um
but yeah i like to do like two to a
month you know
and then i don't know
i'm working on material i figure i'll do
another special at some point but like
i've done three i don't want to like
i'm not trying to rush anything you know
what i mean
three i've done one
that's the only one really is yeah
everything else was just so when you go
now you go
oh yeah yeah so when you go now you do
new [ __ ] you do some of this stuff from
the special no i'm done no you're done
yeah i'm done
yeah but that was the worst that was the
worst period of my life after usual
a.d after a special [ __ ] yeah those
first 90 days were brutal tough because
you really want to kick that material
you're like i'm done with this yeah yeah
yeah but you got nothing else yeah yeah
yeah and you go back to it you're like
damn it yeah so for three months you're
wrestling with yourself i think i shot
in october and i think i was a mess till
february wow february started getting my
bearings back yeah yeah yeah but before
that i was like this is yeah
starting from before it's weird because
now when you drop something everybody
[ __ ] sees if they're fans of yours
they see in the first three days so now
if they're coming to see you in [ __ ]
austin they're like where's the new [ __ ]
you're like oh [ __ ] it's three days
after my special came out
you know what i mean how [ __ ] crazy i
know it's [ __ ] crazy they used to
catch it on a tuesday night at nine
o'clock
you know maybe 10 people seen it in the
[ __ ] club but now everybody's seen it
and they're getting them out quickly too
now like yours was out a couple months
after you shot weeks six weeks oh i know
yeah six weeks now wow six weeks i shot
october 19th it came out december 6th
that's insane i was shocked though mine
was quick when they were like december 6
i was like what wow yeah they started
[ __ ] that that night yeah yeah like
as soon as they [ __ ]
as soon as they just started that night
so yeah
i would assume like comedians used to
have a lot longer to build the next
hour because you it had to get edited
and then broadcast or in a movie theater
and that can take up to a year sometimes
yeah
yeah yeah i'm thinking next time to
really write like an hour 45 right and
then do yeah do 50. yeah i did that keep
30 and go at least i got something
i did that after my second one i had
like so much other material after my
first one something like that but yeah i
had so much other material i was like i
could just put this one on the second
one i think it was after the first one
yeah were you at this weekend
i'm doing colleges i'm doing uh phil
i'll be in philly in dallas but then i'm
in um
charlotte north carolina next week
like in two weekends or something so you
got some time yeah i got finally yeah
good for you yeah yeah yeah and how was
the movie you did uh it was good it's
actually called life in a year i think
it comes out at the beginning of next
year but it was a will smith produced it
it was with cara de levine and jayden
smith and scuba getting juniors in it
and me
it's a cool movie
movies i mean that was a drama
so it was just cool i like that yeah i
love doing it i just want to do like if
people are like don't you want to do
comedies and you're like
i already do the best version of that i
do stand up i do i do what i think is
the funniest [ __ ]
already
what do i want to be in a [ __ ] movie
where there's seven guys and someone
else wrote it and then they're like no
don't say it that way say it this way
the [ __ ] you talking about i do stand up
i do stand up like i do the bio okay
cool let me shoot this and then tomorrow
let me go play the [ __ ]
theater and do exactly what i want to do
so it's like i only want to do stuff
if it's like interesting to me and this
movie was the character that i played
was really interesting and it's a drama
and i'm like and so people are like the
movie's about car de la vina is dying
and so people were like did you have fun
on the movie it's like it's not fun
doing drama that's not the right word
but it's it's it's definitely
uh it's you know it's interesting and it
makes you feel a certain way that like
i'm happy i did it for sure but it's not
like like you know you're doing scenes
where like she's dying and you're crying
and then it's like cut and then you're
like okay let me go back to my trailer
and just chill for a little bit and so
it's not like when you're shooting a
comedy it's just like everyone's [ __ ]
rambunctious and making fun of each
other but yeah it was fun i want to do
drama that's what i want to do i want to
do a lot of dramas i want to do action
that's what i want to do the most is
action really [ __ ] yeah would you be
like the comedic relief in the end but i
don't i it doesn't matter just i want to
have a gun i want to run after somebody
on a bus that's what i want to [ __ ]
do
i got i want to do that so [ __ ] bad
you're ready for lethal weapon yeah just
a remake any movie yeah let me do it i'm
so [ __ ] gonna do it so bad how many
movies have you worked on
i don't know seven what do you like more
movies or tv i mean tv is cool because
it comes out quick
you know like when you're on a show it
comes out every week and then movies i
did a movie three and a half years ago
it still didn't come out yet we just got
a distributor and it's a fun you know it
was good movies it got a good cast
you know it's like what's happening with
this [ __ ] how is it doing tv live that
must have been fun it was insane yeah it
was so fun it was i mean if you're gonna
do a multi-camera sitcom i think that's
the way to do it you know it's just high
octane we shot it
and it aired while we shot it i mean
it's insane the last season i think the
last season on database yeah right yeah
yeah yeah
you you would shoot it live and millions
of people will be watching it and they
were like don't say [ __ ] because then
nbc gets charged seven million dollars
and you're like damn
i could [ __ ] this up
you know
yeah
so i would die i would say i can't
handle bro we'd get the script we'd get
the script
no [ __ ] sometimes we get the script
that day
the creator would be like hey sorry
and i'd be like it's okay but
like i remember looking at him bill
lawrence the creator of the show and
being like i'm gonna and thinking
and saying this
and saying i'm gonna i said i'm gonna
try my best
like it's not like like imagine saying
that to like steven spielberg in a movie
he'd be like oh you're fired but like
you're like oh i got the script today
all i can do is do my best that's what
you do you'd have monologues and [ __ ]
he'd be and he and i and i said i'll try
my best i remember saying i'll try my
best and i remember him looking at me
and saying yeah that's all i can ask for
and then we shoot at [ __ ] 6 p.m or
whatever
live on the east coast
and and you're doing monologues and
you're like i think that's when you talk
about like knowing the character
you you wouldn't even memorize the lines
you just memorize the the intonation
yeah and the idea of the line because
you're like as long as i know what the
scene's about yeah it was [ __ ] crazy
so fun you'd cut we'd do one scene in a
bar
cut to another you're in the next scene
you have to run over change your jacket
and be like hey what's up guys
i'm been you know just
cooking food or whatever the [ __ ]
scene was it's so funny it's so fun and
and then the audience loved it when they
could see you [ __ ] up of course you know
you're still putting on your jacket
there was one scene where the guy was
still putting on his jacket and
you know it's fun it was what was the
last show to shoot that way
when you were shooting i know they had a
drop history yeah um i think the last
one that did it uh and i don't think
they didn't do it um
they didn't do every episode but i think
the last show that did it was that show
remember that show rock with charles s
dutton
yes they did i think they did one or two
episodes like that right 30 rock did too
right but but but that but that was not
a multi-camera live sitcom with an
audience oh but yeah like er did it too
but that's you know our drama
let's do that [ __ ] oh yeah way back then
yeah that's how they did it the
honeymooners and [ __ ] i think that's how
they did it right because i heard a
story one time that that was ralph's
main thing
that the honeymooners would be on tv
and he would never have the last scene
or something crazy he would run through
the ball right as the credits were
rolling oh and [ __ ] with the bartender
oh gotcha
so that was right i wasn't sure if that
was why that i wasn't sure before i said
it that's why i wonder if they said well
you guys are going to be in the elite
history of tv shows
i know ricky ricardo did it he had three
because he started the three crammers
shoot
oh really yeah if it wasn't for ricky
was the one that said why is there only
one white guy on the camera oh really
let's put two more white guys and get
the party started why aren't we [ __ ]
sitting here so i know he had to be a
three camera i don't know what the
honeymooners was i think the honeymoon
was one camera maybe like that
chris man i wanted to have you on here
for a long time i think you're a
interesting little [ __ ] thanks
man no i appreciate you i always wanted
to do it [ __ ] make me laugh my ass
off yeah well likewise i went down there
early last night
because i i just saw the thing that
crystal league let me go down there
early there's nothing i like more in the
world
like nothing pisses me off more when i
get really high i go down there an hour
and a half early and those back seats
are taken oh yeah yeah yeah my [ __ ]
blood pressure boils do you understand
me because nobody knows that i just want
to go back there and sit and if i could
have a beard yeah and a hat and like a
[ __ ] really really 800 pound fat boy
yeah i would just sit back there at
night because i i don't understand if
people know how much fun it is
yeah just to go back there sometimes
like i love it i love and i'm a comic i
will it's hard for me to watch specials
yeah watch every [ __ ] show you're on
right but there's nothing that makes my
dick harder like when they call me you
have 10 45 and i go perv yeah yeah yeah
i'm gonna take the baby swimming i'm
gonna go eat dinner with them and then
i'm getting the [ __ ] out of it that's
cool i'm gonna sneak into the store with
nobody see him yeah
i used to sit all the way in the back i
used to not sit
in mitzi's chairs in the backpack like
in the thing yeah i used to sit back
there
and have really this is way before you
got there one time there was this chick
called the mayor
lamar was mitzi's
hair
chick she's just so one day mitzi going
you want to be a comic come to the star
so they passed her
the mayor was 50 something when she
became a regular
but she was all patched up yeah head to
toe plastic surgery jesus it was all
rubber her face didn't even move anymore
at the store
and one night i got really [ __ ]
stoned i just went back there and i'm
sitting in the back
and she's on stage and she's when you
get stoned i become your act
like that's the difference common gets
high yeah and i go to see the leah yeah
if delia intrigues me no i become
deleted yeah yeah and i'm on stage and
i'm cheering for delete and i'm cheering
yeah yeah but she says this line she
goes
come on people everybody thinks i do
plastic surgery i swear to god i have
never ever ever done a bit of plastic
surgery and in my
reefer
yeah though
i go
that's [ __ ] like just
just without even i would never heckle
another comic that is the most difficult
who said that back then and me and tommy
and a bunch of other conversations were
[ __ ] howling because i didn't even
realize i had said yeah yeah yeah yeah i
just [ __ ] but that's the reaction
that's why because i was in there so
deep like last night i was watching ally
yeah and i think i who else red is
easier and then they said he ain't
coming you're running late do you want
to go up like all right i'll [ __ ] go
up i didn't think you were going to show
up but whatever yeah but that's one of
my favorite things in the world that to
me is how i learn comedy i just sit back
here i watch three four comments yeah
and i abandon ship sometimes i don't
even care if i go up sometimes i'm happy
i didn't go up i just went to learn
that's cool and i always pick up a
little something that [ __ ] night
you were talking about that little
[ __ ] hole
at the airport the airplane oh yeah yeah
yeah dog you didn't hear me because i'm
not one of those [ __ ] from san
francisco comics always go ah oh dude
that's that drives me [ __ ] that you
say
you will never hear me you will never
ever hear me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll
tell you i'll be boring
yeah [ __ ] killing me tonight and when
i tell you that is because i was bent
over yeah and i was howling you're never
going to hear me with that gorilla
laughing yeah
yeah yeah i would never embarrass you
but that night when you were talking
about the [ __ ] hole yeah because one
day i got really high on one of those
edibles yeah and i'm sitting there
looking at that hole for like an hour
yeah and that very next day i know
that's why and you're going off on the
hole and i'm back there
this is what i mean it's just cool man
like when people say well i went to see
a movie and it was an escape let me tell
you something dog i'm 54. i've never
escaped in the movie there's been like
three or four yeah i hear you've escaped
that but with stand-up comedy i love
when the comic takes me for a ride yeah
i'm gonna be honest with you lately
you're one of the few guys that takes me
for a ride thanks and that's why i had
you on the podcast bro
that means a lot coming from you no man
you inspired me like when i saw you at
the live factor i went home then i said
well
i watched because i wasn't going to go
back to the store they called me that
friday
uh
adam had called me and i had a spot at
the lab factory i saw you i'm like i
don't know if i could handle that [ __ ]
and then i watched that movie being
there yeah i love it that's one of my
always so good yeah
and i said maybe it's a sign from god
maybe i should go back to the store well
i'm [ __ ] so glad you came back to the
competition you're a [ __ ] great guy
wow the gentleman thanks man having you
there though you [ __ ] me i love this
comedy store already having you there
it's [ __ ] awesome man it's [ __ ]
cool get down there man so thank you
thank you for taking the time to come on
thank you man it meant the world to me
i'm just gonna give some shout out to
read blue apron and get you the [ __ ] out
of here
pass it over with the uncle show me that
thank you brother
first of all my girl cleo the one by one
podcast
the cobra cats podcast you're [ __ ]
doing great they were voted the best of
austin
oh very nice
lauren rosenker greg and lin up in
seattle randy bowman
dr rox quadrax and gotha i love you
[ __ ]
don't forget i'm at the pittsburgh
improv next weekend
the 28th of october first where are you
at next weekend bubba uh charlotte in
two weeks charlotte that's a good
[ __ ] club yeah the comedy zone is
awesome yeah i love that place let me
talk to you people real quick about blue
apron i'll get you the hell out of here
like i said the beginning of the show
it's the number one fresh ingredient and
recipe delivery service in the country
their mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible
to everybody okay
for less than ten dollars per meal blue
apron will deliver seasonal recipes
along with proportioned ingredients
to make delicious home-cooked meals
choose from a variety of new recipes
each week
or let brew aprons with culinary team
just surprise you just like that
recipes are not repeated within a year
so you'll never get bored
customize your recipes each week based
on your preferences you don't like
broccoli we will send you broccoli blue
blue apron has several delivery options
so you can choose what fits your needs
and there's no weekly commitment so you
only get the deliveries when you want
each meal will come with a step-by-step
easy to follow recipe card and
proportional ingredients that could be
prepared
in 40 minutes or less who's better than
you you get home tired bam 40 [ __ ]
minutes you're eating
blue apron has a freshness guarantee
that promises every ingredient in your
delivery arrives ready to cook although
make it right amazing customer service
amazing customer service this week's
menu soy glazed pork with rice cakes
with bok choy and marinated green beans
skillet vegetable chili with cornmeal
and cheddar drop biscuits that's just a
few
go to blueapron.com right now check out
this week's menu and i'm going to give
you your first three meals for free with
free shipping by going to boyappin.com
joey
you're going to love how good it tastes
how good it feels to create incredible
home-cooked meals
with blue apron that's blueapron.com
joey all right
blue apron a better way to cook and
don't forget honest.com
for all your supplements whether you got
shroom tech
or [ __ ] uh hemp forced protein or
strong bone that air for you
go to honey.com right now and press
church bam and get 10 percent off
[ __ ] delivered right the house i want
to thank chris to lee again thank you i
want to thank my little brother lisa
and i want to thank you [ __ ] savages
for listening
and for being family like i said i'll
see you next week at the pittsburgh
improv
also thank you very much for the
donations
for my niece she's up to 17 grand uh
you guys i can't ever repay you so thank
you very much
i'll be in philly next weekend visiting
her at the hospital so
thank you for brightening up her spirits
and whatnot she even called me the other
day and said [ __ ] the flying jew
donated i said lee's a bad [ __ ]
thank you for listening i want to thank
my brother crystal chris wake up where
can they find your dates at
crystallia.com that's [ __ ] easy
love you [ __ ] have a great
weekend
stay black what we decide on
the ojs oh [ __ ] happy rosh hashanah to
all the jews
you